pues muchos ya califican a la tormenta
Elliot como la tormenta del siglo Y es
que decenas de miles de personas Siguen
sin electricidad la alerta de tormenta
siguió vigente hasta el martes a la una
de la tarde Además solo en el estado de
Nueva York en Búfalo concretamente se
calcula que la tasa de muertos ya que
deja esta tormenta es de 28 personas a
nivel nacional es de 52 personas que la
tormenta Elliot deja esto además pues eh
implica muchos riesgos y muchos
esfuerzos de búsqueda de personas que se
dice que siguen atrapadas debajo de los
cerca de un metro y 30 centímetros de
nieve que han caído en el norte y en el
noreste de Estados Unidos esta tormenta
además pues deja ya como lo mencionaba
graves daños a la infraestructura
energética del país y por eso pues el
del presidente después de que la
gobernadora del estado de Nueva York
haya declarado el estado de emergencia
el presidente también declara el estado
de emergencia y esto entonces habilita
para que se usen fondos se usen personal
y se usen recursos federales para
asistir al estado de Nueva York
concretamente el departamento de
seguridad nacional y el FEMA trabajarán
juntos para asistir a las personas que
pues lo requieran dada esta emergencia
esta Tormenta del siglo como califican
muchos en Nueva York desde la Casa
Blanca el presidente y su esposa
han elaborado y han enviado oraciones a
los más afectados por